don't bring anyone love into this you
know we should ask Miss Pat what
remember that girl we had last week who
was dropping n bombs left and right yeah
oh yeah we do we have her on yes yes
watch this video and I don't know let's
start there is there ever a time when
it's okay for a white person to drop the
n-bomb like if they hang out right so
now this person's get real comfortable
like real comfortable just here you
watch oh stop she looked she looked over
my shoulder phone she started report
right yeah but have you seen this
already yeah she's real pumped that's
the whole thing so I actually said if
you can hear her that she's dating a
black guy this is the white lady we
played last week who's dropping in bumps
and Ashley says she's dating a black guy
so she feels like she can right right
wait I haven't seen my nigga if I come
and get my pussy ain't why you hos just
saying I mean this is by the way the
beginning of it oh she real black right
she's she blacker than me she got the
lips in this bitch is black
I mean you what can you say with a white
girl got she got this bitch how clone
some nigga
yes she's on clone estimation blade I
mean she got the neck twist and looking
a lip no we were talking about that's
how familiar and like how she's all
about you yeah she's more than black
dick
Yeah right I Spit on snus and chill and
I don't see near super chance
you were ever living anyway but I still
kept on shoot I don't care what race you
are baby I'm not racist
you bitches just got me fucked up but
it's just the black bitches that's
talking so that's why I said black
bitches they don't beat high I got hurt
her they're gonna beat her now do you
think she's ever as probably why she's
talking shit like this cuz she's never
had a fight like she's never had her ass
well she gonna know she gonna get her
ass beat yeah so you don't get all right
now she will he probably gonna beat her
ass but it just amazed me cuz oh I'm
looking at a white girl but I'm hearing
a system yeah right yes I mean she got
the demeanor all down so she she could
really play that that game I play with
you when you cheated on but I mean she
would really fool people right yeah she
would she got it down hmm wait so okay
so this is the debate is like she
culturally looks like Rachel Dolezal
yeah that whole bag of worms okay
culturally she identifies this way but
is it ever okay no it's never okay
because if she was standing in a group
and don't care how much you my friend
yeah you cannot you can't say that she
wouldn't and she think she would
no no way no let me tell you something
about when the white people say that
yeah yeah yeah
honestly we feel it I mean it's like
yeah we know listen we feel it like if
you if you stuck your hand on a hot
stove for some reason when it comes out
of a con cake Caucasian mouth yeah
anybody other than black like we do it
just a throwaway but when you say it
hurt yeah it fucking hurts I totally
believe you I totally believe now she's
all black I don't feel it hurt thing
like I totally believe that do you feel
like it's different when somebody does
it hurt when somebody is trying to
trying to
appropriate and like drop it casually
like oh you know I'm saying like when
someone drops it like that yeah you
still feel me still feel like pain like
in her contact shoot that would be that
what you're saying yeah you will see
that that will upset you
yeah yeah it was like it would be whoo
it will feel like rate it racism yes we
will feel it yeah
casually I mean if you're doing it me no
matter what we feel it yeah and it's
crazy it is correct and I think it just
passed down through our ancestors
through slaves we feel that pain from
that word and you know we and I am she
to do with slavery but it's just it's
automatically hate when it comes out of
somebody else's mouth and I think the
reason why we said so much because it
was said to our ancestors so much and it
was saying to you know in the sixties
and stuff to hurt us so much now we
finally got control of the word sure
yeah I know you said nobody ever taught
white people they can't say it it's not
just a lot of things right I guess
that's enough marching an ass-kicking
wipe you just realize no we don't go and
let y'all have that work yeah yeah well
some of them some of them somehow I mean
the way we going now with our
administration it's free to do whatever
the hell you wanted what's her accent
where is she from
she sounds so hard like naughty Alabama
see I was thought I thought yeah Alabama
I heard Atlanta but yeah she could be
Georgia - she's a dddg what I was
telling her was that I thought if she
lived in Georgia she lived like 40 miles
outside of Atlanta you know like she
lived know she could be right down to
west anywhere repair I mean she got the
demeanor the neck Road that's how they
talked down sir so fastly you know
somebody were she said I'm like well
fuck that me so she got UTI rap song
I guess I can understand ti but some
light migos I'm like I don't know fucked
amigos are saying at all
my Sami recognize shit I'm night you
reppin this shit but you fell to high
school graduation test turn that shit
off I read with amigo as I said I don't
know what the fuck they just mean either
boozy Ashley just be bad and wealthy I
don't know yeah it's oh yeah amigos
things are phenomena to me I don't even
know you guys are talking about I had
his fucking little ripples in the world
I'm laying yeah I'm stuck in the 90s
she's a different level of white to me
not that you need I'm white soon I got
health care
[Music]